sheriff Scott Israel was grilled by Jake
Tapper on Sunday where the officials did
everything possible to avoid blame for
the blunders leading to the parklands
shooting at times he seemed like he was
reading from a fortune cookie do you
think that if the Broward Sheriff's
Office had done things differently this
shooting might not have happened
listen if ifs and buts were candy and
nuts you know Oh Jay Simpson would still
be in the record books I don't know what
that means
dead people and there's a whole long
list of things your department could
have done differently oh man I don't
know if ifs and buts were candy and nuts
this jackass would be out on his butt
mm-hmm at least I made it rhyme it
wasn't the same word but he also said
this with a straight face are you really
not taking any responsibility for the
multiple red flags that were brought to
the attention of the Broward Sheriff's
Office about this shooter before the
incident Jake I could only take
responsibility for what I knew about ie
exercises my due diligence
I've given amazing leadership to this
age amazing leaders amazing see he's
less a sheriff and more a politician and
like a politician he's just trying to
cover his butt hoping the media focuses
on other things like ending evil NRA
discounts which does nothing to stop
what happened in parkland and so we keep
hearing more about the mistakes that
authorities received many tips warning
them that Cruz was going to do something
bad
including potentially a mass shooting
and then there are the deputies failing
to confront the shooter
the sheriff denied these facts before
and now does all he can to save his job
including throwing one deputy under the
bus I gave him a gun I gave him a badge
I gave him the training if he didn't
have the heart to go in that's not my
responsibility
that's some leader but should you be
surprised remember the CNN Town Hall
knowing the lapses in his leadership he
diverted the audience away from his own
incompetence toward Dana lash who
probably would have done a better job
than him I understand you're standing up
for the NRA and I understand that's what
you're supposed to do but you just told
this group of people that you are
standing up
them you're not standing up for them
that's the real disgrace knowing what he
knew then and playing that card for
applause so maybe you should be mad but
not at the NRA at this dope Kimberly
when he says when he was talking about
that deputy and he says you know he's
only responsible up to a point
it's he right that like he wasn't there
so it wasn't his problem I mean just the
language his rhetoric really just shows
his lack of integrity his lack of
leadership skills and qualities he is
the head boss he should the won't be the
one taking ownership of this situation
and really making it a teachable moment
and saying that this was in fact
something that they could have done
better that the deputy should have gone
in that they've had the training that
they should like reexamine situations
like this maybe they're not making it
real enough so that people aren't
confronted enough of situations like
this to be able to make those snap
decision you know judgments and this
this guy seems like he's just playing to
the theater you know that he's thinks
he's some character flawed for sure in a
Shakespearean play and he wants to just
play to the crowd and the more agile
ation that they give him that the better
he feels and you just see it by those
moments especially because when you know
what he knew at the time how he behaved
in the Town Hall I mean that's why
people some people are calling for him
to resign yeah or at least be suspended
Jesse I don't know what he I when he
said he he was mentioned his amazing
leadership I think he's trying to steal
from Donald Trump vernacular but it
didn't work it's like if Hillary after
Benghazi had prayed her amazing
leadership it doesn't make sense to me
as a political animal and he acts like a
politician because he doesn't accept
responsibility this guy switched parties
to run for office he was accused of
running a patron patronage mill and at
this point he has now compared himself
to MLK Ghandi and Abraham Lincoln that's
it yeah so he sounds like your typical
politician so the one deputy didn't go
into the building and then when more
deputies showed up they didn't go into
the building so they were either cowards
they broke protocol or had the wrong
protocol we're gonna find out which one
that is we also know that they were
called 23 times about this guy two of
those times they were warned that he was
going to be a possible school shooter
and now he's running a PR campaign he's
going on CNN and blaming the RA and not
accepting responsibility and he's taking
credit away from the other department
that should have been his own deputies
it almost seems like he's more concerned
with bashing the NRA than solving the
school safety issue and Democrats who
for the last several years have said
that police departments need to be held
to a higher standard need more
supervision need more scrutiny now they
really have no appetite to look into the
sheriff Republicans usually give police
the benefit of the doubt but at this
point there's looks like there's a lot
of mistakes that were made and
Republican doesn't want to investigate
here I think that's fine investigate let
the facts fall where they may
I just don't want to see a cover-up
because it sounds like there may be a
cover-up going on hmm
Dana when you watched the Jake Tapper
interview I guess it was on Sunday do
you think he realized that the sheriff
had fleeced him at the Town Hall and
this was like payback he's like good all
right you knew all this stuff but he
does it in a way that's classy right he
doesn't drag him through the mud gave
him a chance to answer and the answers
as you pointed out and you showed it
were horrible there was no sympathy for
victims or the families there was no
defense it was all defensiveness and
quite honestly I thought it was delusion
and I do wonder if he actually thinks
that he did nothing wrong but I believe
that in the military right if if your
soldiers don't follow through like
you're responsible or else it doesn't
work it doesn't yet change yeah if you
don't have a chain of command that is
followed then it will the chain will
break mm-hmm what do you what do you
think he deserves some kind of
discipline I mean there is talk of
suspension or should he resign the
government the governor can fire him
even though he's an elected official I
believe this whole conversation is just
to me like way off in the weeds
somewhere I mean I to me what we're what
we need to be talking about is what
happened with those young people who are
dead hmm and that's what we're doing
well I don't think so I think that's
somebody we have to take that shooter
would be alive but go ahead well no I
mean president from today's
even without a weapon he would have run
in right but that's that's the point is
the dead young people right and so to me
well you see now this rush of
Republicans to blame the FBI to blame
the the sheriff of the county never ever
to talk about the NRA the proliferation
of guns in this society that a wacko
young man isn't who's you know underage
under-21s able to get an assault rifle
to me this is where the conversation
should be so we can go back and forth
about whether or not you should fire
Sheriff Israel fine I don't know that
was the topic today why just we often
talked about practical solutions for the
last 20 not a practical solution I think
it is if you're responsible for what
happened that's these young people
person and stop more shootings in the
future then we you know what we should
imprison anybody because that doesn't
bring back the dead nobody murders
somebody don't put him in jail because I
gonna bring back two dead oh that's
that's exactly opposite of what you
would normally argue where you say
things like the death penalty and strong
punishment will interact discourage
repeat crimes in this case I don't see
that going after this Sheriff or even
the deputy and by the way Dana he thinks
that he did a good job his lawyer put
out a statement saying he thought he was
the first to call and I'm not talking
about Peterson okay but I'm saying in
terms of this conversation about this
Sheriff it seems to me it's almost like
a political ploy by Republicans to get
attention away from the things that
politics started in the town hall when
he tried to divert the responsibility
for his actions on the Dana Lodge that
was the political move okay you want to
talk about the NRA and you want to talk
about solutions to prevent future gun
violence let's roll this tape of Donald
Trump actually mentioning the NRA mm-hmm
in an interesting way today don't worry
about the NRA they're on our side you
guys have for you are so afraid of the
NRA there's nothing to be afraid of and
you know what if then our with you we
have to fight him every once in a while
that's okay they're doing what they
think is right I will tell you they are
doing what they think is right but
sometimes we're going to have to be very
tough and we're gonna have to fight them
but we need strong background checks for
a long period of time people resisted
that but now people I think are really
into it so Jesse how political is that
that seems like the most
middle-of-the-road he goes to one hand
and the other on in the NRA I mean it's
pretty honest and it's for a politician
that takes a lot of courage to take on
someone that's been back in your party
for decades Juan makes this point like
you can't chew gum and walk at the same
time Republicans have criticized the FBI
this sheriff and Republicans have also
put forth solutions to school safety by
taking on the NRA and saying raise the
limit for purchasing an ar-15 by banning
bumped stocks expanding background
checks all we've heard from the left is
let's just crucify the NRA I'm glad that
all of a sudden you think police just
need to be trusted willy-nilly and
everything they do is perfect because
now when they do make mistakes you
should be able to hold police
accountable yes but I didn't say I
believe these people are paid for by tax
fair money and if they make a mistake
they should be held accountable for the
federal government but you want to give
them a pass they don't know why why do
you say something you just said it you
don't care it doesn't matter I diversion
here this is a diversion but let me just
come to Europe it's not the bump stops
right sure along his Congress had since
Vegas - how long has prison had
everybody that's not a version could
nothing sadder if something had been
done Kimberly was raising her hand yes
but not raising an arm just so here's
the problem here I think that you know
if we really just want to be honest
about it all these things should be
examined and looked at and to be fair to
give credit the President did have a
listening session to discuss this
objective bring up weapons they did
bring up guns president is one of the
first people to come out and say look we
have to take an examination of all this
and what happened maybe we need to raise
the age maybe we should make it so that
you know bump stocks aren't you know
available etc so all these things are in
play but it doesn't mean that we should
be derelict in our duty to do an
examination of the sheriff's department
just like we've done to the FBI to make
sure that the right protocols are in
place to make sure that this doesn't
happen again that is healthy it is
responsible and it is comp
see and that's what we need to focus on
here so all of this is appropriate
discussion just like we should discuss
the sheriff here Israel and whether or
not he is the right person to be doing
that job I think the answer is clear
yeah you know you know Dana when we talk
about diversions and political agendas
it's it's like the NRA discount story is
kind of like a diversion a wave like you
we everybody here at this table and and
and and Donald Trump and his listening
event we there's everything from civil
civil tags to hardening soft targets how
does like how does killing abandoning
NRA discounts or getting rid of that
does that help so there was a rash of it
right so United Airlines Enterprise
rent-a-car I think Hertz joined in and
now Delta and so in this scenario I I
understand that look there's going to be
opposition to the NRA just like there is
opposition to Planned Parenthood right
it's like the mirror organizations for
ideology but in this situation when you
we've talked about see something say
something should lead to do something we
know that the do something did not
happen in this case so why would you
take that out on dues-paying members of
the NRA who want to rent a car from you
oh why are you punishing them it doesn't
make sense and then it gets even worse
yeah I think because now elected
official in Georgia is saying oh yeah
Delta well we're going to come back at
you and take away your tax break this is
actually going to lead nowhere because a
corporation has the right to make a
decision if they want to lose customers
fine
yeah I mean if it means that much to
them and they want to take the PR hit
for it or maybe they think that they get
good PR out of this they've made that
calculation as a business I don't think
the government should come in then and
try to punish them and lastly this
sheriff is the reason why people want to
arm themselves because they don't
believe the sheriff can protect their
safety as they didn't this time we want
to be able to protect themselves either
work this time right yeah an enterprise
should probably focus more on the safety
of their cars than this you had a bad
experience some people have had bad
experiences and you can google that